welcome to occasionally awesome of nick
yusuf i'm kevin christie today we are
doing our intro with our guests hi my
name is Jason TV yeah it's easier it
isn't there just here that's like so
what should we say on their behalf uh
let's plug some stuff first where you
have anything coming up meat nope just
uh go to punch on sports calm and listen
to you my podcast with Sam Tripoli and
Ari Shaffir that's every Tuesday every
tuesday from nuna too yeah so you can
stream that live right streaming live on
Fox sports.com yep porn and then on I
grab my 19th in at it and then on the
twitter at the t th e te eb and then
your Instagram those different Instagram
is my actual name at Jason tebow j-a-y
som thi ba ult how many people woulda
guessed it was felt that way I'm
Canadian nightmare the Y in the first
name I'm federal already throws you off
and then Tebow when I jewelers on Google
when I first learned how to spell that
I'm like oh they do that no your name is
a Sudoku yep yeah ungoogleable oh yeah
that's exactly what I am yeah on google
which is easier to pronounce than Jason
tema yep and I just wanted this guy with
my exact name on twitter and that's his
Twitter handle but no y in his first
name ok and I just somebody said
something to him and he goes I think
you're looking for at the teep that's
hilarious I'm goes man with your name
and it's such a you know rare ish name
yeah I bet you get hit up from a bunch
of weird stuff from all yeah we're back
up at you guys to look exactly monster
goes yeah actually about once a week I
get it up with some pretty love that I
love that right anyone with a name
similar to a comic must have the
weirdest few days on Twitter were there
like what the [ __ ] is poor people
yelling at me for I didn't do anything i
know the google the guys like oh this
guy says something offensive or a driver
right hold some weird sex related thing
out of the bag of bev never said mexican
shouldn't vote yeah that's funny are you
on the road anywhere are you doing any
with no I'm still here but can please
continue watching masters of sex
everyone that is and says nice things I
appreciate it live episodes left five
episodes left ok I next weekend I'm
gonna be a Denver comedy works so those
of you who live in Denver Colorado that
gig Denver Comedy Works the downtown
location September 3rd 4th 5th halloween
weekend San Francisco me and Andy Haynes
were co-headlining with San Francisco
punched blonde bun yeah and then I think
that's it right now oh this wednesday
sorry that's tomorrow because yeah this
will be out tuesday so tomorrow night
another installment of the workshop show
brand new material from a bunch of funny
comics in LA so if you live in LA that's
wednesday 8 p.m. at the comedy store
with the lineup which i'm looking up in
a second sorry joe roe god now he's not
oh yeah he had a gig come up so he's not
there any sends his apologies because he
was for up until like the day ago so
it's going to be me hosting uh comedy
store employee newer newer comedian Abby
robear's he's going to be opening the
show Sam Tripoli who we all know and
love from the punch drunk podcast and
the naughty show Steve rent is easy from
the league uh a buddy of mine jf Harris
who just moved out here from New York
funny comic uh Yassir Lester guest of
this podcast garbage can also
um he is gonna be on the gym with that
noted hey yeah noted hater Yassir Lester
I just finished writing on the show
girls so we can't just talking with that
and then the very lovely the very funny
miss Nikki Glaser so that's the lineup
right now so those are all [ __ ]
hilarious comics I'll do new stuff 8pm
uh at the comedy store in the belly room
tickets on the website I just tweeted
about it so you can find the link there
that's that um so yeah teeb you just got
back to LA and we had you on the episode
and yeah ambush yeah there was an ambush
will we asked you what your five
favorite song desert island songs an
episode that we have yet to do ourselves
yep but for some reason we were like
let's ambush guests when we have got a
couple I got a couple do you get a
couple and you guys have to listen to
the episode to see what they are um and
how many times have you done the show
now twice duh this is either two or
three two you did the radiohead one yeah
this might be my second time ok second
and then Jerry's our legacy guessed
right yep he's done 3 3 ok um so you got
one more and then you're tied wow yeah
this is intro count as one nope because
this is the same FSA me Jerry yeah so
he's in the lead he's our like a sea
gust right now I think a term he came up
with before himself was at the seeker
head would I heard yeah he yeah the
being of the most common guess was
really that's a war he's waging on his
old days on he fits for some real-ass
like right away is like am I am I the
one who's known must we're like I think
we didn't really matter to him maybe
probably yeah but he was like I'm the
legacy guest yeah Wow which is a great
term is it makes it sound like he's been
on 80 of them I know like a legacy go
Don Rickles of The Tonight Show yeah
right right right um ok so we thank you
for being on it
thanks for having me guys yeah and
welcome back to los animales oh yes it
is yeah we just like it ambushed we
should we shot the [ __ ] we talked about
a lot of music we ambushed you we talked
about celebrities and fame a little bit
later he's a lot at the 80s we covered a
lot of ground and it was fun so we hope
you guys enjoy this episode with the art
good buddy the tea but see you guys
later [ __ ] it
okay I wonder where that fear you think
comes from well I mean having money tied
up into a house I'm sure well at one
point I had all this money and then I
put his house and then I was I had a
plan and I did what I had my plan was
going really well I did what everyone
said you're supposed to do and then the
whole plan fell apart right they think
that so I'm used to like something big
and catastrophic happening every so
often so my head is just like around the
corner I guess it's like the closest
thing opening your own restaurant or
business you put all this money in and
you're like this could go to [ __ ] and
there's nothing that can stop a [ __ ] if
it does yeah and I'm like completely I
what can i do to undo it yeah yeah yeah
there's like not a there's no like easy
well you just do this like once I was
actually thinking about I was driving up
Laurel Canyon and I don't know if you
guys remember this but there was a house
that just slid down the hill yeah yeah
no yeah and then they just left it there
for like a decade because no one would
buy the land and they couldn't sell out
I heard the guy was like suing somebody
will they finally built a new house
they're like but it's at the bottom so
it's not on the same area that slid but
like I Drive by that I'm like [ __ ] that
house like I just in my head don't trust
it at all they're supposed to be this
like big El Nino this winter like the
biggest one that's what I here too so
I'm wondering what's going to happen to
all those houses on that like the shores
of like Malibu and all that stuff my
march for decades they've been saying
like one of these days yeah you know
something [ __ ] title with Leslie
Grossman's parents owned a house right
on the beach there yeah and I don't know
if it's just because of sure erosion or
what but she told me they lost like a
hundred or 200 feet of beach it like in
this band like a year and a half that we
used to be basically kind of their front
yard the ocean came that much closer to
the were they had to put like rocks and
stuff because it was like eroding and
eroding in a row so happens when you try
and just turn nature that part of nature
into your front yard I word an ocean I
was working in Northern California
what's in santa rosa there's all these
like kind of
cliff houses and I someone told me like
you're allowed to scoot your house back
one time and though it'll be covered by
your insurance but after that they're
like look ticket you put your because
the show the cliffs just keep hoping I
want that insurance to be called scoot
insurance like on the form of your car
or to scoot you pay the extra 30 grand
will give you a third scoot yeah after
two will be paid for by you dude it must
be a fortune it cannot be cheap to scoot
an entire house a house at 200 feet I
still am amazed every time I see like uh
18 wheelers moving entire house up they
caught him in half yeah I put one half
on each truck and they're just like
driving on the five you're the house I
know I always follow them for a while
some just like house house car car car
yeah you're like how how does that even
[ __ ] work you just uproot like that
the house is on a foundation yeah how do
you just like cut it out the only I've
never understood the foundation because
I there was a house in Eagle Rock they
did that too yeah and I drove by it
enough times it was near Al's house to
where I kind of saw it in process they
just jack it up slowly and then it just
plays pop it off like a toupee let's
stick it on the thing it's insane I
don't know how it they're able to once
they put it in the new place for it to
still be at all structurally sound cuz
it's just rattling around the whole time
maybe they just drill it in from the
inside into the ground what's the
equivalent of that in Chicago like the
Malibu like we're all the rich people so
what do they call it the Gold Coast riot
on like all along Lake Shore yeah in
Michigan is there like any threat of
waves destroying the houses not really I
mean that's where like all the rich
people are that live in the city but
right like you know there's little
beaches which used to be bigger but not
a lot isn't the thing in Chicago that
some of those like row houses are so old
they're [ __ ] legit crooked after a
while some of them yeah yeah yeah all
that whole area I think what does a call
the architecture walk or something and
all of those buildings like all along
you have like you know plaques on them
that like you know so-and-so used to
live here you know right yeah I think
the deal is with that is when something
does go wrong you're then bound by some
bizarre historical landmark thing to
where you can't just like fix it
normally yeah yeah go thing has to be
what do they call that it has to be a
historically accurate yes that's what it
is to an extent so I mean they got like
slaves working in there and stuff right
black people's us to enter to the
service aha beauty of your we have to
hire a Chinese person to renovate this
floor yeah exactly if you're drinking
fountain breaks I like is it a black 100
i won my black guy drinking fountain
broke I wonder when they're gonna do
that to the comedy store get it turned
into historical and always thinking
about that the other day well isn't it
that is it some weird thing to where
it's not tech they don't own the thing
they honored that weird lease was all
that [ __ ] about well you can get the
actual business the building turned into
a historical landmark you have to like
apply for it and all that stuff I just
don't know that they've ever done it I'm
surprised only been successful for such
a short amount of time I think up until
this point the in a city like LA and
nothing is that old everything is torn
down and rebuilt like a place like the
comedy store that's been around for 42
years is it's pretty old and it was
zeros before that and so the actual
place has like a lot of history LA but I
wonder if it's just the shores cuz for a
while it was doing so bad it was always
like well they could sell it make the
parking lot make more money if they just
didn't think to do it for what that was
the exact quote you would here for about
10 years yeah puts it out store which
they make more money if it's a parking
lot I know get so scared when people say
that [ __ ] was it was so real OD later no
it's like women you know you hear your
parents fighting like I'm gonna believe
me I'm gonna be gone forever yeah don't
leave mom well I used to talk about that
with people that there was like a about
50 dudes that would have just been we
would have just been like walking the
streets of Hollywood confused oh yeah
historical probably more than that they
were
been so many Friday nights or saturday
that's where I would have just been I
would have found myself heading to the
store cuz I'm like I don't have anything
else to do right now and I would just
and then I go oh yeah it's a parking lot
now yeah that would be so weird cuz you
know you usually use our spot there yeah
or you do a show somewhere else and then
go there Mingo hang out there yeah
what's going on where would we go in
comedians die Oh detective hey respect
sir yeah I guess you go to the neural
behind funeral without free booze like
the night that the day they die yeah
don't you hear about it everyone just
kind of goes to the store to be with
each other like be with other com yeah
that's a weird thing yeah like where
would that happen I don't know probably
helps to scare me so much when I would
hear that and I would always pretend it
didn't scare may be like yeah I mean
let's go get spot somewhere else and
then just be like we're in my head I
literally am a go where Yeah Yeah right
there was no like good ice house back
then there was no West Side comedy
theater back then no yeah there was the
improv The Laugh Factory and the comedy
store yeah and that was it that was it
as far as like legit good places it's
like go to the west side brook home more
often I check out that West like stress
yeah prospects seems bleak right
dublin's hey now I was like on fire
again it's weird um should we start the
ambush what ambush his ambush oh yeah if
you want yeah I'm being ambushed this is
our first ambush episode nice ambush
segment in an episode yeah yeah it's not
going to stay secret that long when
people listen to a thing I go no we
don't hurt you ambush I there we do
different question ambush uh okay right
now top of your head desert island five
songs oh Jesus for the rest of your
existence yeah oh my god isn't it the
worst that's a horrible done are you
were supposed to do an episode we've
been putting it off for close to six
months because we couldn't pick we've
done a an episode where it was the the
five songs that didn't make our top five
before we've actually done the top
that's a horrible question because
the words it's the worst because it so
depends on your mood I mean this I know
if I'm in a great if I'm in a mood you
know there could be five songs that are
absolutely that list and you know if I'm
in like you know depressed there's a
total different five songs hey Nick
though you seem to start breaking it up
by those categories you're like a song
for what I'm sad a song for what I'm
happy nostalgia song yeah because the
way I see it I'm heading to uh like a
deserted island forever right and I'm
like leaving this life and I have to
factor it in that what I want like a
thing for every mood and like it's
something i'm on a deserted island music
the rest of my life i have one that i
know because it's in it's actually easy
pick you can't say it though okay have
to save it for our episode alright which
we have to do soon I mean what the [ __ ]
to be fair I think you're having more
problems with I am yeah well it's really
tough it's really hard I've gotten three
of the five what three are they I can't
say well I'll tell you about the reason
this all came up is because when i first
started hanging out with who is now my
current girlfriend she randomly texted
me one night we were just texting each
other she goes 10 favorite bands and i
went into a [ __ ] tailspin attends a
lot better than 10 the number 10 is
better than five and bands is better
than songs rack it's it's easier yes I
mean I went into a total I went into a
full meltdown yeah because I came up
with Ted it took me about an hour and a
half on the fly but then we start I
started realizing the band's I forgot
and then it just turned into this year
spiral where I was like holy [ __ ] my ten
didn't have the pixies and then it was
like well I have to kill myself became
awful it also be a alternative like it
was super fun but it's because you start
to not only do you start to think what
do I love but what do I want people to
know I love you start to lay this yeah I
really really try to the office but yeah
you judge how did that into it yeah
that's what that's what became cut yet
remember we had we didn't know each
other that long
this was like I could really hurt trying
to impress her to a certain degree yet
okay guys already had sex yet no yeah
this that's definitely like in the early
flirty stages yes you gotta make sure
that list is strong it was had to be
strong yeah you might say what like your
break but it was definitely like what
we're like what are your top five bands
what was it in any particular order is
in a particular order I cuz I has to be
I was freaking out so immediately I was
like this isn't in order but it was like
radiant you know it was like Radiohead
sure Tom Petty built to spill okay I
think I I for some reason missed the
pixies and then put them back on yeah
those Pixies who'd you removed to put
the Pixies on I don't remember I might
have been like public enemy or something
okay god damn it was a mess dude yeah it
was a mess so right now in this like say
you're getting on the plane right now to
go to this island [ __ ] what five songs
do you take I mean it I it it'll
probably change 10 times throughout this
podcast right and I'm gonna be texting
both of you all night long [ __ ] i forgot
about this song's god yeah i would
probably hard you want one of my songs
that didn't make my top five but made
the second five sure my network my
number one radio a head song was a
polyethylene i love that [ __ ] song
that's I think it's my favorite
radiohead song even saying that loud
makes me nervous because what did you
yeah change your mind in four minutes
probably gee I mean it this is so hard
really it really is it's almost I know
it's going to do is I I made I I got to
my I don't like have a Beatles song and
you I don't have a Beatles song and I'm
in my head I'm like do you really not
have a Beatles song yeah i don't think i
would have a Beatles song yeah me
neither positive i wouldn't i had a
stone song before I beetle son yeah oh
man I you almost have to like go through
you meet you music and I would have a
print song I'm gonna
would probably have a prince song and
argue with that which one ah Purple Rain
[ __ ] may ah that's tough too I love I
love pink cashmere I'd probably have a
tupac song right ok um God definitely
probably uh I mean you almost have to go
like what bands would absolutely like
this so i would have a probably will
probably you are my face ok would be my
Wilco song yeah almost like start with
like you're like who are the bands and
then you're like okay what's my favorite
song that's what I tried doing even
ashes the American flag I love to yeah I
tried doing that too I was like well
start with my favorite bands but then
I'm like but then you got five songs for
every goddamn band I know so some and
then sometimes you're like I don't know
if any of theirs would make it onto a
one song for the rest of my life that's
the thing yeah that's what you're like I
mean you know a plus I'm like I'm on a
tropical island am I only have some sort
of like you almost feel like I know and
like the songs that are really long I
thought about that so many people have
said that but I'm like you do free bird
and bohemian rhapsody or like they go a
lot of places there long yeah but then
you still have like 30 years on that so
what's a seven minute song really gonna
do I know trailer Dead has that one I
think what is the century of self or
whatever album that is weird the whole
town is on one song the punch brothers
have songs that are like 20 minutes long
and you're like you know just from a not
getting bored perspective it's worth it
to consider a little just a longer song
you're like I write a symphony I might
have a clean song that dude you can't
you can't tell someone not to have a
queen song that's for sure I god it's
hard right it does it makes you feel it
makes me feel bad on the inside like
I've have anxiety yeah it's all cause
this it causes anxiety yeah that
question could yeah cuz you don't let
yourself down honey if it's 20 dude I
could at 20 even yeah you could rattle
off 12 and not regret them because I ate
more but when you have five yeah you're
like for the five for the rest of your
life yeah yeah I get it Mick I get it
for the problem ah [ __ ] that's really
hard it sounds like the one you picked
so far as you are my face is that you
specified there are other ones you just
pick the art you like I'd have a prince
song uh Anna quick I I would that's a
song that just never gets old to me yeah
uh I agree and it's kind of like
all-encompassing mood-wise right you
didn't mean cuz that's an that's a huge
factor two were you like if you really
thought about it a lot like what's the
song you never turn off you never turn
it off you never get sick of it because
as songs i love that you know I listened
to him for a while and then I'm like ah
so sick of the Sun you know yeah and
then you don't listen to it for years
there's some songs oh I won't turn off
because they're almost like I like them
I like them because they were so stupid
and I still but it's not like I love
that like a rusted root sent me on my
way won't turn it off I don't know why I
like it it's tied right on my top five
yeah but like I won't turn it off every
time comes out like yeah mechanic that
might be a reason to put the song maybe
like gives you the giggles yeah
something so ridiculous that like you
love it yeah like I'm not like a like a
eight I realize I went to this club
recently I had to I went to a club for
someone's birthday for the girls club
yet nightclub for my girls birthday it's
like loud bottle service night yeah but
it's um it's at this hotel on wilshire
but it's all 80 seemed to like an 80s
bar and go through a the doors a vending
machine look whatever I realized I
[ __ ] love eighties music way more
than I thought really I was it I hate
clubs I had the best time and then all
of a sudden they were breakdance they
had a breakdancer performance did you
break dance no no I otherwise everybody
break dance the bar like like sunk down
and then there was a mini stage for
break dancers in a Michael Jackson
impersonator and for like only eight is
this place sounds awesome I know all
right it's some new Hotel on Wilshire in
what Hollywood event own crazy okay it's
cut like this slot Silas likes like a
short word like that so terrible
something yeah but this club I guess is
like really hard like I you know they're
hard to get in like very hard into I
guess because it's it's [ __ ] funny
[ __ ]
well as any age music makes the club not
that creepy cuz no ones like getting all
like gross and fired up and like really
meet douchey yet doesn't make a douche
yeah right like a director ran song and
then the pet shop boys yeah Depeche Mode
you're like every song comes on at least
20 were like [ __ ] yeah this I went to an
80s themed bar in uh Houston when I was
there and it was like the whole place
was decked out in just a tease throwback
retro [ __ ] the pictures of Madonna on
the wall five TVs all like different
music videos in the eighties non Mon
like mute and then like the DJ's playing
eighties music and everyone's dancing
and it was like you're in there and
you're like this is a if this was a
regular bar no theme I would be really
annoyed right now yeah but since there's
so much cool [ __ ] to look at it's like
it's novel for at least 90 minutes no
the people who were like going for it
super hard in a normal place I would be
like like this is gross but like yeah I
looked over to guy who was just having
that he was dancing harder than anyone
in the whole place just cuz he was like
this is my [ __ ] yeah I was like that guy
rules right now because how often when
you get to a certain age you get to
experience all your a childhood [ __ ] in
one place yeah with a hundred other
people but there was a lot of people
there the group of people I was there
with were probably 10 years younger than
me uh-huh and they were still super into
it but like what it was like so this
music like means something to you I was
like oh yeah i was like i had i bought
this record like me and my brother
bought this record at like a record
store like a real record because it was
a record yeah not ironically bought like
something on wax I Bob had to listen to
it there's no other way ya know like we
bought a journey record like I bought
that [ __ ] and tried to draw the cover
like we bought that [ __ ] on there at the
record store on foothill that's now the
osh we missed 8tracks 8tracks bias yeah
I was like Rob for us but albums be fair
we were I was we were big in late it was
a cassette tape time from cassette tapes
were like and when I was at the age of
like oh I have my own musical taste now
and I want to purchase music myself it
was all tapes yeah those were a cheaper
and CDs came around I'm like
mana one with all these tapes CDs came
out before tapes too yeah but they just
never took off in popularity until I
think I'm having to pose for like
someone invented the digital photo or
Lizzie the digital foot or the mp3 like
20 years before they released it in some
guy codec was like we're not putting
that out yet those yeah the photo photo
edition what it's like we can't do that
right now everything like that was
invented years before any practical use
mp3 was invented somewhere in the 90s
and then who are like oh no to do this
animal was like like you could use this
to play music for free forever yeah good
topple this entire industry right we
could upend the entire recording
industry in like a year and a half yeah
thousands and thousands of uh the music
executives gonna be out of work with
this is this that cool it it George
Lucas said he has developed the he has
developed a kind of like shortcut to
computer animation or some [ __ ] or
something having to do with cameras
where he was like oh I can't I can't
tell anyone cuz it kill like he says
like it would kill like 50,000 jobs like
it's a kind of either editing type thing
he's figured out or animation thing
where he's like it would put out it
would put thousands of people out of
work right it would just make doing
something that takes like five people
take like a dude right yeah but that's
like that's one of those mistakes though
that people make where they they try and
like suppress some sort of technology
that you have no control over its gonna
make its way out that's the way
technology works sure it keeps going
forward whether you like it or not and
then they go like know people will lose
jobs but then it's eventually going to
come out and then someone will either do
it for free or not find a way to
monetize it and then it's gonna destroy
all those jobs anyway and they'll take a
long longer time like bounce back as
this tangent helps you come up with any
songs I have been thinking about it it's
hard to not think about just now talking
about age music I was like do I put
don't forget about me by simple minds on
mine I love that [ __ ] song yeah
goodbye horses it's really hard
think the 80s are an underrated decade
for music considered kanekalon but those
songs were like well crafted the good
ones were like excellently produced yeah
there was indeed there was good music in
the eighth is for sure yeah but it kind
of gets lumped together like our did not
give you Eagle song in their animals are
great I was listen to the Eagles
yesterday you know like the Eagles don't
why is that I don't I never it or not
that I think maybe cuz i've never
listened to them so i only run
California there it's only hotel yo
seventies ban oh then you don't not like
the Eagles you just don't know that you
think I just I ever heard him it's same
Wilco I've never heard that still I can
accept that shocks me I can't I know
everything about you I know I don't know
wanna be I don't know why anyone never
told me to get away I have been telling
you nobody told me when I was younger
when it was duck I did not younger what
like a year ago no like eight years ago
10 years ago again I was still pretty
old well young you sanglant liked in
your 20s when like bands really get to
you well you when you're in your
twenties I don't think Wilkos exactly
how long's welcome an event since 97 a
f56 yeah with a [ __ ] in 20 years old in
98 but they weren't like I mean had one
album there was no I would have it's
weird that I that would have been a band
I would have gotten into then it's weird
that I didn't like I was I mean if you
like built to spill liking Wilkos not
that big of a leap uh somewhat I mean
early welco was like not like built to
spill and no one really knew I mean they
had people knew them in that around that
like son volt golden smog kind of like
all before all country was even a right
and but it was like maybe in the early
to mid-2000s people were like we'll go I
just like there's what you have movie
came out I think in like two thousand or
whenever that was I remember when the
movie came out and I still I still was
like yeah I don't know I don't know this
i've heard of this band and everyone
likes them but like I don't know what's
going on with it yeah yeah i think when
that movie came up i think they got a
lot of people like into him that's the
son of a landline by the way you guys
just I don't know what you're really on
line I have a landline I was gonna say
where the [ __ ] is not coming
from I have a landline because I have a
home alarm did you ate that lay in light
of that 80's party that you would too
they're giving out landlines autumn good
one yeah they gave way phones for a
minute I thought like his a window was
open and that was the neighbor's phone
I'm like I guess he lives next to a 97
year old grandmother you have to have a
landline to have a house alarm home
security system oh really yeah yeah I
remember telling you a long time ago
Mike Weir talk about some kings of leon
album or something and i was like have
you heard the latest wilco not alike
will call like really why I guys is this
suck I think maybe I did you associated
them with like douchebag hipsters that
listen to him and then I was like I've
just heard like one song and it seemed
like in my head I can't remember
anything I've ever heard of will go but
in my head like when I think of them I
think maybe I heard just like a sleepy
like a slow one that was like odd seems
boring right and then I'd like a
specific read you're like I don't like
their music and then only like douche
bag might have been that moon that movie
came out people kind of freaked out like
they became like I was like why does
this man have a movie I haven't even the
concert film that one yeah I'm trying to
break your heart another original the
black and white one oh yeah yeah where
they the talking with ya the documentary
I remember thinking like weird to this
band is a documentary yeah and so I just
never but then I go I've gone through
phases where I just don't investigate
music for a long time I can get like
that sometimes but then I get so bored
of now it's like anything like if you
have spotify I don't even need to really
even actively look for new music because
it sends me a notification hey there's
five new albums out today and you're
like oh cool yeah or even like about
artists that you like the like hey Ryan
Adams just uploaded 17 new EP yeah that
happens every day to get a notification
every day that literally happens every
day but Ryan Adams is another one if you
listen to him oh god I don't like I
haven't see there you go again you
started I don't like me like Oh what I
heard I didn't you've heard that someone
I love
strums cover album the one but when he
did that strokes cover album I've never
even heard them remember that I would
absolutely would not put it past him he
covered it is it I don't even remember
that he's covering taylor swift's new
zone right now and it sounds pretty fun
sounds cool yeah it really sounds cool
yeah I'm people would always tell me
about whiskeytown whiskeytown awesome
that was around early well co2 that was
in that little that same little world
remember seeing a Ryung at Ryan Adams
music video another Simon not being like
yeah he's he's really really great he's
he he'd probably have one of my five
songs for sure but Jesus cry or was it
may be whiskeytown or that come pick me
up but that's one that like after a
while I start to get sick of it okay
like you hear it so much write that song
ahh winding wheel i love winding wheel
which one which albums out on uh i think
it's actually might be a whiskeytown
song but he always sings at every piece
but you be hard-pressed as human concert
i'm not saying that vm arizona um at the
stressful ambush really is are you know
that's like a question where you like
okay in two months give me your answer
to this you guys have any I know I know
never reluctant to even make eye contact
with this question propose do you have
songs that have have major final five
yeah hey you have I III of the sign up
two spots left yeah and they're hard to
fail is a tool song one of them for you
possibly uh-huh and see that's that's
what's so difficult about this list is
they are my favorite band but when it
comes to like five songs for the rest of
your life I'm like I'd would want to
make it yeah exactly it's like it's hot
it doesn't even really have to be from
like oh these are my love these don't
even have to be your five favorite songs
no they're like they're like the five
most useful yes they're like the ooh I
like bohemian rhapsody to me it's so
beautiful it also rocks hard right it's
also a story right
right murder right it's an episode of
CSI right like it to me like you know
what that one that one clicks off a lot
of boxes of things you'd want to hear ya
Freddie Mercury's voice yeah which is
incredible don't stop me now is another
good Queen zone mm-hmm I love that tune
yeah there's a lot of [ __ ] and the
more music you listen to the more songs
there are two pick from and then you
train going crazy purple rain though
yeah yeah but like do you put what do
not put a Michael Jackson song I don't I
probably don't I love PYT oh man that's
a that really got to me that maybe
there's some songs that are off on off
the wall yeah that that white PYT may be
my favorite dance song that's up there
man that song is a [ __ ] masterpiece
sure like if that song comes on you
don't want to dance something happened
that that you you don't like dancing
that song is so good thriller and off
the wall might be the best one to turn
the beat around of i wanna rock with you
anybody's like you know you know history
discography of you know yeah of in you
know sure he did it you know chillin
albums before that now for that but
right there to go off the wall which is
a great out yeah and then a followed up
with riller that might be the best one
too that's a solid that's the best one
to that mean consider that back to back
album city did that one as a favor to
the the record executive that ran
whatever label already which was very
gory i think so i don't know i think
that's right yeah and then he he's like
we need we need to hit for our label and
then he did then he did thriller so it
wasn't even like he took five years like
carefully cry was just like y'all knock
that up for a thriller yeah 3 I mean you
don't have it you don't have any
anything off thriller at the top five
that seems not I mean
and some but there's also that element
of of this that's like there's a certain
artists that like I've heard they kind
of were overkill for me growing up so
that at the sauna so to do it for me
like that's what I feel is always a
shame I've heard them so many times that
they're kind of just permanently in my
head anyway so I don't need them on the
i right that's a great apply no
thrillers so much that I you know if I
hear it I feel like I'm always hearing
is like seven Led Zeppelin songs that
have already been ingrained in my mind
tour but the Beatles all that might be a
little make it me too may hear that ever
the Beatles Nirvana go oh boy yeah yeah
yeahs nervo just doesn't even now the
stones I got in too late so like a part
of me is like maybe one of theirs oh I
know a song that might I I might have
another permanent one which tough to
make it i mean like i say it out loud
and say they feel about after the words
leave your mouth Aurora by the foo
fighters really I love that [ __ ] young I
never ever get sick on interesting it's
such an awesome like the drum beat to it
uh-huh I love it that might that's a
weird one I know yeah I'd like every
time that song but it's not my falafel I
love it that's your personal where
someone might clown you like a music
nerd book and give you a break it's the
only fighter song I haven't saved in my
inbox yeah yeah you know I don't have a
lot of the albums but I have that one
song yeah that's the thing with the Foo
Fighters is there not a bad bit like a
great fun of Kyle like they do and
you're like why they're all talented
you're great they make like catchy good
like well-crafted pops off sure I love
never record these records great yeah
second records pretty good yeah they
were like there are good songs on it but
i don't know maybe they just ended up
like getting attached to like a younger
demographic and then people got old they
found him kind of cheesy or corny maybe
but Dave Grohl himself is the coolest
dude yeah and he was in [ __ ] nirvana
it's like how do you I don't know if
you're if you leave nirvan personally
you're the drummer of Nevada not even
like you're not the guitar player
he got ya if you started even half a
decent band sure he made another huge
band and then he made another band where
he wasn't even the drummer yeah I know
it was all self-taught he grew up in
like the DC punk scene and laugh [ __ ]
did you know he got out of high school I
think yeah yeah he toured with uh why
camera the name of the huge [ __ ]
peter witt Tom Petty after Tom Petty's
drummer left the vent but in some punk
being he went on the road with for a
while it was like black fly it was some
some ban on that level in the punk scene
magnet and then he ended up joining
Nirvana so he's like from the get-go has
been involved in cool [ __ ] and he's as
talented cool dude just for putting Pat
smear in his band like work yeah like
you like the germs that much you're like
no no but you want to be in the Foo
Fighters and he is like a like a lover
of music oh yeah he bought um whose
drums maybe John Bonham's drums really
and just has him like as like art in his
house like yeah glam they just sit in a
[ __ ] corner of his house like just
watching sonic highway the jockey series
you're just like this guy is lives and
breathes me they organize the Foo
Fighters organized they rickrolled the
Westboro Baptist Church like over the
weekend yeah i saw that what happened I
guess the bat Westboro Baptist Church
we're gonna protest something to be
dicks and so they're so ridiculous the
Foo Fighters they showed up and like
basically rick rolled them like tons and
tons of people showed up and just have
like a [ __ ] super gay ass dance party
like really overwhelmed them to where
they just couldn't be heard on any level
yeah I'd punch I mean come on I didn't
take them seriously nobody don't know it
was like it's a joke it's like Trump
running for president come on they
picketed Harris whittles like they just
look at who's and they look they
basically go on Twitter and look what's
trending and then go at that and pick at
that uh-huh yeah well they're getting
attention i guess guys that's really all
they won't you know how small that group
is there's like set there's like a like
a hundred people in their in their
congregation it's tiny yeah they're just
so loud about it on
the internet you know there's e signs
who can I piss off to get attention like
I'm no I'm gonna hurt somebody literally
get on the news by making poster board
signs yeah if you they just make super
ballsy signs at like a kinkos yeah
they'll be like what's the word now
that's like God's happy this person died
that is there their whole trip yeah it's
like God wanted this person to die and
that's how they've gotten on the news
protesters dude when I was in terms of
the punch line is a hotel across the
street for me was like there was some
sort of strike happening I mean these
two hotels are directly across the
street from all the one of those union
strikes yes sir and at seven o'clock
they had like am aight guys am maybe
even before 7am they had these like
eight guys that were just marching
around in a circle to bull horns and two
of them had a pan yeah pots and pan like
a man on a big rock and their chant was
for everybody to wake up and check out
of this hotel oh my god their intention
was to wake let it wake it woke
everybody else up at the hotel across
the street my hotel we don't have a dog
in this fight yeah yeah but they're
waking and they're like a chant was like
you know check yeah check out don't
check in you know everybody wake up and
check out of this hotel and all this and
you just laying there just blinking like
I'm gonna [ __ ] murder somebody yeah
so I went down to the you know the place
like we're all the freaking dental
breakfast is and all that [ __ ] is and
I'm just like what what what's here that
I can throw it I throw yeah I guess I
got bunch of apples yeah and I just went
back up to my window and I was just
throwing apples across the [ __ ] yes
yeah I wonder what there's got to be
some sort of law that like that prevents
protesters from like disturbing the
peace yeah what's in but you can't just
do anything you want when you're
protesting you can chant I mean you
never get a champ but there's got to be
some sort of limit to how
loud and disruptive how mad I was you
have no idea and you know word we work
late at night yeah you know I was still
up at [ __ ] 330 yeah just laying in my
[ __ ] hotel room yeah and then four
hours later right when I'm you know
sleep yeah he's [ __ ] like us
Flintstone like protests go or five of
them were like really mangy looking like
homeless people you know they were just
like here's twenty bucks yeah just
repeat what I say yeah I got a bullhorn
I'm a union guy yeah right and they'd
protested for like an hour I wanted to
go which is what you said something to
remind remind me of this whole story but
I wanted to go show up like four or five
guys show up pull up in a van next to
them start marching around them with no
protesting signs yeah so like no more
protest actually protesting a protest
right and then I wanted a third van
which is one guy that protests the
protesters you know no more protesting
protesters that's so go it just gets
bigger and bigger yeah you don't even
know what the [ __ ] these guys are
testing that would be so great um i'm
trying i'm still trying songs i can't do
it i think i got to okay i have to what
was your second one well the Foo
Fighters song and then the wilco song
you're my face however an Aurora I I'm
pretty positive give any slow jams ah
that's a good question both of those are
arguably slower um but I may have a slow
jam I almost certainly would have a
tupac song which one that's a tough one
slow jam maybe maybe I mean do you take
a song on the desert island then it
makes you cry I mean I can pretty much
it makes you sad yeah cuz there's so
many things you can think about like it
reflect on in life that are like sad but
not necessarily in a bad way especially
after a while and I'm totally alone on
this island right
yeah yeah it's just I did a good song to
beat off to oh yeah there's some of
those like Dre ones raised like but
everybody on the chronic there's some
imbeciles in between chronic worry about
funny that was somebody's five songs
just a little in-between moments that
run like rap song that's the worst we'll
just somehow weed and that people
smoking weed siren is a lot of shots on
doggy style oh I hate the skits when
they pop up on your [ __ ] phone your
liquid oh look I've got dammit you can
forward it yeah interlude noises
interlude yeah wow man this that's
really when you buy a hip-hop album the
Niger black why are there 28 tracks on
there exactly in the eighth song yeah
eight songs 28 tracks exactly it would
just be dude like you're like yeah man
these [ __ ] don't all their
buddies just seeing people been saying
you fell off like six different tracks
of that uh-huh exactly hard tire screech
kakakakakakaka shots yep then then the
song starts sirens there's an eminem
album that definitely has 22 tracks on
it a lot of Eminem sells had those like
little especially the marshall mathers
oh yeah I'd like beating up his wife
every other song had some sort of little
sketch yes incredible huh he was pretty
great did I love white America that
songs great uh oh that's a song the way
I am is exactly why the way I'm is great
the way of his def stan was either
really a virgin white America though I
love that [ __ ] song god that's why I
think that'd be my favorite Eminem song
do I have a slug do you have a slow jam
yeah do you have a slow jam I was trying
to think of what I don't know it's hard
to really commit to one of those I never
put a slow jam on ever no no when I was
it never like a like hey man we play
some music like it a reason ranking yeah
I never do like a sexy play it's just
like a playlist of a bunch of stuff
maybe a portishead yeah maybe the
massive attack low yes I've ever played
music for a chick it was because like oh
we both like this
band are like I want to turn you on to a
band yeah it's never been like I'm gonna
put on some Luther Vandross oh yeah yeah
get it let Al Green Goddess into the
night mmm guidance yeah we're athlete
it's a weird al green on alone it
depends on the girl to some chicks are
like I'm not into this ship oh I know
some girls like put on like Slayer and
[ __ ] you know yeah hard rock and then
some girls are like oh something like
Indira it's just yeah dude part of me
wants to put andrew WK song on just a
[ __ ] when I want to run around the
island yeah wow I mean are you till you
puke you like our that's one of the
songs you put on after you figured out
how to like make your own like little
umbrella out of like leaves in a twig
and then you stick it in the first
coconut you've cracked up and and then
you're sitting out of the sand did you
like a [ __ ] yeah you know what I way
what about like a like a good mash up
like a good like girl talk cuz I has so
are we going 37 songs from the 97 in
like yeah seven minutes I guess you
could do that yeah you could take a girl
talks on cuz that mean you know that
some of those songs go like fast slow it
has everything in it yeah they get a lot
of like classics yeah I guess you could
do that I mean I don't know any of those
songs are called number three number
track for Jack 5 i'm surprised that guy
hasn't come out of the new album yet
boys waiting for more stuff to sample
he's literally sampled all the songs
ever last 25 years ago he has like 10
years in between yeah album because he
examples discography is like the
collected works of the history of all
music I know I know if you had to take a
stand up album what do you take whew
that's hard and is hard I would take
probably see I don't know that's hard I
got my frap top my head I thought
delirious stop not owning this would be
up there although I popped in i watch
delirious the other day I will Nereus
yeah i watch delirious
and the like gay guy stuff at the
beginning sounds real different now it
sure does I was it's real sharpened mean
you're just like it really is it's so
immediate it sort of but like to hear it
it was like all I it actually felt like
it bothered me to hear it yep it was
really interesting so I I knew it what I
know it was there I remember it all but
hearing now you're like ooh dang dude I
know it's [ __ ] up yeah some of that
summer I mean it's gonna be a lot of
that too when we like this other
comedians and stuff and comedy movies
we're gonna look back and they're like
other saying words that we don't say any
more interesting yeah I mean that dire
straits all races [ __ ] like 20 times
yeah it is just gonna be a lot of that
now we're gonna go oh whoa forgot about
that yeah had people used to be so
insensitive towards each other it's
almost like it the way the way a the
joke kills and the casual initially ooo
yeah ooo yeah his rough everything he
did killed yeah he used another guy and
there's also that same era you know yeah
that 80's in that same you know thriller
and all that he was a guy that just was
on top of the [ __ ] world when I years
old cut and basically conquered it yeah
at 22 yeah it's like well I beat a beat
comedy but yeah I be comedy yeah I
killed one more ok I have all been one
more but then I guess I'll be done with
stand up because I basically beat it I
finished it I gotta finish comedy if you
really did get to the end and just
dusted off his hands is that I what's
next movie star like yeah I'll take that
yeah I'll do that why'd he come back
you're like he beat it why did I need to
yeah same thing with Jim Carrey yeah you
know everyone's me he was at the store
the other night and was like you know I
wouldna be honest we make it a show if
he yeah yeah yeah he was there for that
but that guys still doing that show
about the store whatever people there's
a different writer and switch Showtime
yeah I'm dying up here whatever page
numbers turning the book into a show
yeah yes yes and the writers from
masters of sex is writing it
that you get to Showtime thing right
yeah um you know that got the dialogue
of like man what if he came back and
started doing stand-up here how awesome
that baby like why would he he has he's
undefeated all he can do is lose Yeah
right and cause himself stress yeah it's
like it's either you you never you've
had to never quit doing it and that's
the only way you could be like oh yeah
that guys still doing stand-up like
Chris Rock Jerry Seinfeld they've never
saw them Liam's yeah Robin lay they
never stopped but for someone like
accomplish that much and then quit for
20 years like going back would be a
waste of time like Laura Seinfeld was
saying Lauren Michaels would offer him
like watch come our NBC and laura
michaels and people like that would be
like make a sitcom he was like why I
made the best one yeah this why would I
more I think I was the best they come
but he's not going to make one better he
just isn't it would be impossible he
would have to do something completely
different yeah like the way ray romano
did men of a certain age right which was
great it was totally different yeah you
gotta go in a different you can't just
copy the same thing cuz all people are
gonna do is like well that's just one in
a certain point Cosby tartu that second
show and even if Alicia Rashad and it
was like nope you hit a certain point of
stardom where you get typecast as
yourself yeah you're so famous that
people only see you as Bill Cosby yeah
you're Jordan on the Wizards yeah like
you're his bill cosby's name on every
show he's ever been on has been Bill
Cosby he actually has been able to untie
custom say I managed to find a way to do
if someone was brave enough to crisis
way I live yeah I will rape my way out
of being typecast as the good guy yeah
you got you know who I feel I feel real
bad for the the cast of the other people
in the cosby show that now get don't get
their residual you're getting i would
i'd put on the low end i'd say 50 grand
a year taken away from each of them easy
that TV Land [ __ ] maybe more they should
I wonder if they could sue him for that
I wonder I
oh no it wasn't his decision true you
know what I mean it was his actions yeah
I doubt it that there's no way got so
much way do you think he cut small
checks like sorry you no way that guys
it's no one's more self-involved oh yeah
he's there's no way he's giving anyone
anything world's biggest nervous hush
money yeah herpes or hush money yeah
well apparently did give a bunch of hush
money yeah there was like a statute of
limitations on it yeah or whatever it's
like you can't talk about this for 20
years or whatever and it's actually been
yeah like they're like all that's 20
years they'll go away no no yeah i'm
going to wait for 20 years you wanted 20
years in one day i am telling us and
I've got your money you wonder what's
gonna end up happening that did it's so
amazing to me that he you know that you
could get pulled over after having three
beers and spend an entire night in jail
and cost you tens of thousands of
dollars yeah and that happens every day
this guy raped 6e women yeah he is still
walking around signing autographs yeah
yeah and not really denying it he's not
saying he did it but he's not saying he
didn't do it woke up today had breakfast
had some lunch and have some dinner was
a little netflix with my wife even
imagine like yeah in addition with my
wife who you think is he never Google's
his name yeah or watches the news
probably anymore I mean how is he not I
mean maybe in his head he's just like
I'm so close to the finish line like I'm
80 something years old whatever I'm so
close just ignore it until I die also
you've the level of ego that guy had to
have done all that [ __ ] in his headed
but she's like this will pass like I
will get away with it because I always
if clearly associate better so it's just
like I'm me the things like this don't
happen yet I'm the [ __ ] it it'll go away
eventually who do you believe this girl
who's ragi and smells like [ __ ] or move
Bill Cosby yeah yeah akhter Huxtable
yeah I'll just throw on a sweater dr.
Huxtable yeah
maybe we're winning a jello inside when
he if if think about what it would have
been like if none of this had come out
when he died versus what it will be like
it would have been like the UH like
comedy icon like the nation would have
gone into a like a groundbreaking
beloved comedian would have been a month
of morning there would have been TV show
oh yeah rika what NBC would have done a
whole thing it would have been huge yeah
they would around all every episode of
The Cosby Show yeah TV Lantern it
literally it's just like it'll be quiet
and weird it'll be weird now that I like
bad sweater-wearing serial rapist die
like this what Michael Jackson died it
was different I'm ever that changed it
was it was a weird thing it was like a
oh my god Michael Jackson died people
got real bummed and it was like almost
the controversy was like trying to still
come out if you were like yeah but
thriller like it what also died in a
weird way that dress like a young I mean
54 so young I mean that was a d you know
if you heard like a UH one of the golden
girls died right now you like oh yeah
yeah she had a good life yeah ever but
you know you hear you know somebody like
that dies he's so young it's not even on
your radar that Michael Jackson's gonna
die but it also wasn't surprising cuz
his life was so bizarre and weird and
you're like I is one of those guys were
like I wouldn't be surprised that I just
turned up dead one day almost lived a
punishment for a while to like he was
such an odd person you're like you're so
clearly miserable yeah almost like it
made people more sympathetic whether you
thought he did that thing to the kid or
not you're like this guy clearly is a
[ __ ] disaster whereas what it ought
to be merciless he's one of those people
that would have been really awesome to
you know not do it I mean we great
command and guys you have michael
jackson on your podcast I know he's so
awesome but if you could just somehow
circumstantially have honest sit down
talk with him for half hour 45 minutes
would have been awesome yeah I don't
think that would have been possible
after like 1993 yeah but
just as much as you could off the a bet
oh yeah you mean like his you know you
catch him off guard one day maybe
where's chill we had his meds are cuz
you know family he was just medicated to
the tits every day literally to death
yeah he did it until he does yeah it
killed him yeah he was as I do you
remember where you guys were when you
felt when you heard he died found out
before it was even in the news cuz yeah
someone I knew was working in the
hospital uh where he died and i get a
text message Michael Jackson's dead I'm
like that's impossible and I look it up
on a long time for it to be confirmed I
looked it up on the internet there was
no news of it I'm like you're you're
wrong she's like I saw him being moved
into and I'm like no way yeah and then
two or three hours later the first uh
the first headline broke uh news of
Michael Jackson being rushed to hospital
I'm like get the [ __ ] out of here
another hour later he's dead I'm like I
cannot believe yeah it was not I was
borderline obsessed with him as a child
yeah every kid how to party Iowa has a
pin i had a pin and a pin with just his
face on it I sure i'd sell ride the ET
fais pin 20 great even ET wow really
they were like when i was a kid you just
always heard about some parents surprise
their kid by taking them to a Michael
Jackson com yeah I always hated that kid
yet was like [ __ ] that it was it was
like one of those things are like
tickets for three hundred dollars out in
nineteen eighty whatever Beverly running
10 years old and being taken to a
michael job it would have been a memory
that would live well yeah but the rest
your life is downhill from there
probably nothing in your baby's concerts
must have been maybe that's where this
adventure secret I people come from
those ones that are always like
skydiving and rappelling off mountains
they're trying to like top the
experience of seeing Michael John their
attacker they are yeah yeah totally yeah
Jose descanses had to be crazy because
he is it they were an event every single
person that was putting those concerts
together had a coke problem back then
yes so it had to be just everything was
negative pyro sack
yeah man what if we can get elephants in
there right about your elephants look up
elephants every time your eyes settle
down from looking at a huge explosion
michael jackson was moonwalking it never
it never gorgeous coming shooting out of
the town in a jacket with so many more
zippers than even you were prepared to
seeing you with your eyes yeah I mean if
you think about like you know even
movies how movies TV shows everything in
the 80s was directly affected by cocaine
yeah dude I what ghostbusters 2 was on
at the store the other day I watched
like 15 minutes of it it's [ __ ]
ridiculous insane do the part where the
baby gets stolen debate the ghost is the
special effects are so bad the ghost
that steals the baby just kind of floats
laterally flat it's not even even look
like it's flying it looks like it's on a
people mover at the airport and just
like going closer closer closer giving
your baby and then it leaves right the
silliest [ __ ] you ever seen the dude
with the accent the little guy Oh whole
thing yeah the guy with the accent who's
doing terrible ya like like a in prov it
character trip was being written two
seconds before they yelled action Oh
ever it was on blow ya the minute that
thing hit like a hundred million the
other one they're like riding it like I
F we got to do another one of these I
mean back then sequels were like a joke
mean that but it was like the dumbest
thing to do with the exception of like
star wars ones you know those sequels
are a joke back then the original now
everything is a sequel or remake or a
remake a remake yeah I think they should
remake Cannonball Run I never saw that
really good because you can jam it full
of stars whose whose the plot of Burt
Reynolds though well I tell you they
wanted to be Will Ferrell yeah well I
mean it could be you know you need
someone that kind of busy but will
Ferrell pretends to be that ridiculous
words Burt Reynolds at that time
believed it right right right see I
would liked it i would like to cast that
not like super duper super star ish I
mean you got a hella fun of it was like
that all those weird-ass character
actors yeah
you I can't believe you haven't seen
that movie is it great it's called it's
so silly it's just stupid raahil arias
uh-huh like intentionally earns in one
of them yeah yeah yeah I mean it's just
a car race yeah illegal car race across
the country oh cool everybody that's in
the race has a different angle of Y like
Dean Martin in Sammy Davis jr. are
dressed like priests yeah they're
gigantic alcoholics they're always
showing can have a Ferrari wow I didn't
think I pulled over there two priests
but they're hammered the whole time yeah
Dom DeLuise Burt Reynolds have an
ambulance and a crazy with this sounds
great I didn't know awesome I don't know
anything about this movie and a crazy a
doctor that they've rented yeah it was
[ __ ] up in case they get pulled over
they have a real doctor Wow and uh I'm
care costs are remain capture Jackie
cheetah Jackie Chan second his first
movie he's the asian guy that karate
kick holy fish his first move what year
did that come out mateys 82 something
maybe I don't look it up uh yeah but
it's hot and it's you know everybody
that's in this race so you know they'll
meet up at certain checkpoints and bars
and getting fights and yeah I got a lot
of cops they're always like there's a
little just so many seas of them at a
gas station running toward their car to
get back in the ring yeah yeah yeah yeah
other people plop but the end of it the
end of it there's a doubt takes which is
a classic thing so it's scrolling in the
credits and it is a little you know box
yeah I mean nor McDonald's Carson sketch
where he's making fun of like laughs
like laughing too hard on Carson yeah
with Dom DeLuise it's sort of in
reference to the cannonball run out to
ya cuz it's just Burt Reynolds and Dom
DeLuise can't stop laughing yeah Martin
candles again yeah Dean Martin everyone
outtakes and love those though he now
takes are just classic and there was an
episode of the state which i loved the
stage I was just talking about the state
yesterday I love this
de esta me chef you know if your
listeners have never seen a watch estate
is hilarious um one episode of the state
out of nowhere at the very end while
it's rolling credits they down to
costume wardrobe and everything did all
of the outtakes from cannibal run
perfectly I mean like like yeah just
memorized it and they dress the same and
it's just the state credits rolling and
just looked just like it was hilarious
something's what a great idea yeah state
was so good day was great day was great
state was like I wanna rewatch that and
kids in the hall kids and alls great too
you know else is great with strangers
with candy river that strangers candy
for sure that's uh with no I had a
satirist yeah there's a lot of jokes in
the actual tears of that show there's a
lot of jokes in that show now where
you're like they could not get away with
that oh I know there's so many like uh
gay jokes fat jokes black joke like over
your race like whoa under one time she
had somebody Amy Sedaris character had
like captured out i had a prisoner or
something like this are kidnap somebody
and as a knock at the door and she goes
oh she goes hang on I think that's the
UH I think that's the [ __ ] with my [ __ ]
food I know there are so many lines like
that every darn it's a Mexican delivered
age the character is like a former drug
addict yeah rate just ignorant whatever
but like you're just like whoa but
there's so many was now where people
with how overly sensitive everyone is
they would just pick it's offensive
watch but it'll layer you've never seen
them watch Amy Sedaris is Letterman
appearances good they're great yeah
she's so town is great by the way her
Instagram one of my favorites really uh
no power so great it's just weird [ __ ]
she finds and you can imagine what she
finds weird is just better weird another
pill where I ya know her Instagram is so
good yes parents were like will read any
David Sears oh yeah and they'll help get
in a full [ __ ] detail back that's so
great me talk pretty one day I
never laughed out loud is great while
reading that's great holidays on ice is
really good yeah we are engulfed in
flames is very parents and corridors my
sister's favorite authors she she's met
my for four or five times I some redo a
live reading at UCLA I think she every
one of his book signed oh nice that's
cool yeah he's awesome dude yeah he's
awesome yeah have you come up with any
more songs uh pretty impressed you got
to I got two now again like I said I'm
sure I'll to be texting both of you
tonight like hanging up scratch at I
forgot about this right you know cuz
you'll just hear that's what's gonna
happen is I'll hear songs yeah you'll
put on your head from now on what are
you guys gonna do your big announcement
of what yours are I maybe next week we
really need to do it someone tweeted me
the other day like what the hell is this
episode person asked for it you don't
need to show every episode you guys do
you talk about how you are going to do
this no so if we only talked about doing
it in three episodes and then haven't
I've heard about it from a few people
online and a few people in person with
the like are you ever doing this and I'm
like I know we have to i mean i do i
have but then you're like [ __ ] that it
every time you commit to one it's worse
because you have less open spot I now
yes not like man only have 3 i'm really
really good thinking of a third one
reminds you of another artist thats
related to that artist it's like when
you add an artist to spotify they go you
might also enjoy and then you're like oh
yeah yeah exactly i mean a Radiohead I
probably yet is like seven albums of
their leisure right I mean even black
rose to look a lot of food and like
Black Sabbath I wouldn't put us out of
time there's some I woulda dogs I might
put on I wouldn't I don't think I'd have
any hard rocker metal of any kind no
nothing on rock or metal me I mean this
the possibility of a tool song might go
in there but like possibility of a trail
of dead so i might go in there yeah I
don't I mean all the ones I would want
to have on a desert island five would be
like the the lyrics are ultimately the
most important part I mean I
there's a there's ac/dc songs i would
consider there's Beastie Boys songs i
would consider I don't think I would
highway to hell to me like that's
another one where ACDC yeah you can see
back in black I mean [ __ ] I would health
under see those put those like some
songs can give you adrenaline dumps
that's what I'm saying I feel like I
don't need that I like cut down a tree
I'm trying to build exactly are you
exactly like you my mom you know some
high pop music yep right you know if you
think about the island aspect you like
man I'm gonna need you know some Calypso
so I can run to yeah four off the
distance I see a gorilla and I'm like oh
yeah I gotta fight this gorilla I put on
thunderstruck will beat the gorilla in a
hand-to-hand fight I mean you would
definitely you can't fight a gorilla
with some leg you can't fight gorilla to
wilco oh yeah I was gonna say Luther
Vandross but definitely not we'll cover
as I think about it does not many Wilco
songs it would make me wanna fight a
gorilla you only just fight you fight
your regrets too will come that's true
which is why i love them so all right
which is why i'm glad they have so many
albums and so many songs it's equal to
the number of regrets yeah if you like
googled Wilco regret would probably like
seven songs with that word right you
know I mean Britney Spears I could just
do five right there for toxic is a jam
which one was that toxic who knows
something something you're toxic up
ceptin oh yeah I know that song toxic
made me locked my keys in my car one
time why someone called me I was had a
job and this my friend of mine called me
and like as a joke was playing toxic
honest that's one with a weird like one
thing in the beginning maybe maybe so i
think i like to be a lot of rap music
video really yeah dude then you should
love were you really know I grew to hate
it cuz I had to listen to it for eight
hours 70 times but it was the bad part
about dude the person calling me playing
toxic threw off my getting out of the
car routine so I just
and left the key things locked door let
them running no no I was an omniscient
pull it out trying to look up with the
video how's the bad thing about music
videos is then you get that song stuck
in your head I was like ah yeah that was
a later song though it was later but it
she hadn't started to know the paparazzi
in the video other that's not object was
just like lots of green lights this is
different one yeah doesn't know one
maybe I think about britney spears
shaving her head once a week why why it
just gets weirder and weirder me as time
goes on it's funny that you said that
because when you were mentioning that I
in my head was her bald head crazy
there's that one picture for hitting the
paparazzi car with an umbrella yeah like
that was a legitimate public meltdown
gap that she had in front of the entire
world all in the span of like those
happen member of Martin Lawrence had his
yep he's walking down the street with a
gun and [ __ ] see I find those less weird
every single day but that's what I say
when you go when you go when I go back
to I almost think if hers happened now
would be way he would even be bigger but
like it was so like the biggest pop star
in the world just like went to a hair
salon Studio City and shaved her own
head yeah well people photographed it
and there were rumors why but no one
necessarily know the rumor I heard was
that Kevin Federline threatened to take
their kids and said he was gonna get her
drug tested he was cheating on more
drugs can get it they can test your hair
follicles that's true so she shaved her
head it's but then like she shaved head
for and then like her dad became
executor der exchange messages get crazy
at the time there's no way to really
know what her reasoning for anyone she
just lost her [ __ ] mind it was doing
drugs and was just like she just grew up
in the the spotlight all those kids are
[ __ ] up yeah she never on a regulated
no I mean what's her face Miley Cyrus
Michael Jackson that's part of the
reason he's he is the way he was yeah
Britney Spears seems to have gotten back
to normal River Phoenix I've heard that
she'll never have control of her own
estate again because she's still in
saying i think that i read that the
other day okay isn't it but it's her dad
I mean I mean do
who I mean who really knows the inner
workings of yeah that family and why the
new no hot when she first came up every
kid in idea we were just like how do we
that was wrong what they did that was
wrong which is I'm going to
short-circuit every 16 year old boy that
there is yeah and make every girl want
to be this person I mean that [ __ ] was
pretty scandalous they were like let's
take this teenager you know and her
parents were standing right there they
were like a hike up the skirt repairs
like yeah go ahead yep get those fun
bags out yeah let's put in a school girl
out yet yeah we do retails yeah let's do
pig pig tails short skirt mid-drift and
then shirt yeah buhari were standing
there the entire time with the thumbs up
like go ahead Mick G or whoever was
shooting that [ __ ] thing yep let's
how much are we getting paid for this
see high socks sure yeah we stand to
make how many millions this year yeah
show show show the world our daughters
underage tip yeah yeah and let me spread
your ass cheeks open a little bit there
yeah your butthole make the lips make
the lipstick string here no pride part
impreza if I had a kid I would do that a
heartbeat just sell them out absolutely
seven eight nine years old yeah sure
does basically a sec day with jira
sexual and indentured servant yeah if
she's not singing the song it's
basically just the first five minutes of
a pole dance before that I think about
to like yeah well we were at least when
I was a teenager I will she was she was
popular when I was a teenager so for me
there was no weird perverted thing at
all because Britney Spears and I are
literally the same age like six months
apart right um I was old enough to feel
but you not to think when she was being
marketed to America she was being
marketed not mostly two teenagers she's
being marketed to adults yeah so you're
basically peddling child porn yeah at a
bunch of 30 year olds true are happily
watching it and then like jerking off to
it later sure that's the creepy part you
can't I don't think you you cannot you
can't take that thing that that record
companies do with young women out of the
equation of sex
will assault in the country I think you
can't I think it plays a part in the
same way like you know they say video
games can influence violent behavior I
think the same thing that they
fetishized the media has fetishized
younger girls I don't think it
influences it because either you either
have it or you don't but I makes you I
think numb to the idea it makes it more
more normal to find teenage girls
attractive if it's on like if it's in
regular TV and it's being shown to you
in a very normal place you're like oh
it's it's okay to find a high school
girl attractive even though I'm [ __ ]
30 it's on my TV well I think that's any
like as an animal you find young like
women that have like sexual features
attractive right I've known 16 year old
who looks 25 you're gonna find it
attractive but then when you hear oh
that's a 16 year old you're gonna go oh
[ __ ] I didn't remember when I when I
remember Britney Spears you look 25 she
just liked a really overly made-up
teenager to me yes she looked like she
was like 19 or 20 yeah she looked like a
15 year old I was old enough for her to
look young to me like she looked you
know I was significantly older than her
right so I was like this young kid yeah
her and like Christina Aguilera both
like young to me I'm never I never find
it's a dumb statement but yeah you know
like people like Ari Shaffir good friend
work he likes like eight-year-olds haha
yeah he's like 57 I think right now are
we and then he likes girls that are like
they just turned 18 yesterday you know
you argued with me wasn't is not hot
because she is too old and she has
turned the corner uh-uh ariana grande
know basically know who's the girls
[ __ ] so hot she's like swimsuit model
huge tits Oh Kate Upton hate Upton is
too old what he also which are they say
she's too fat I don't think that I don't
think that I don't know if he said that
she's just too old and she's I couldn't
out past her prime that's is like 20
talk to you 34 it's I don't know she's a
hundred
95 Selma Hayek is prouder than almost
everyone rather it what 47 if the aloha
48 yeah like here and she's still
perfect Susan Sarandon so hot yeah she's
still pretty yeah Kate Upton's to old
dude an 18 year old looks like a up like
a they look like I'd like a elementary
school kid to me isn't that crazy you
did all your ears on their faces you
know they don't look like a they don't
like date no no words like when I see
teenagers are just like what you know
they don't look attracted to me at all
I'm actually really glad yeah not
attracted to teenagers at all yeah
they're not in the least bit but there
is a part of me that's and that's
argument to say there's a part of me
that's like the part of me that was 16
yeah like I can look I can see like an
attractive 16 year old girl right and
I'm not attracted to her physically
attracted to my god love the [ __ ] her
whatever you wish you went to your
school when you were 16 is a part of me
that is that right there's a part of me
that's like man if I was 16 that I'd
have a total crush on that chick yeah
you know yeah but that's what I mean
like that's what Holly was good at doing
is taking like a teenager that is too
young and then like dressing them up and
putting them in the right lighting and
then making them look like they're of
age and sexualizing this [ __ ] out of
them and then you're just like dude I
want to [ __ ] her and then they're like
yeah the 16 year old pops is like wait
what age you know but then the people
who are don't care anyway and be like
I'd still [ __ ] those people that their
minds already think that way I thought
Kylie Jenner was like 20 is she's
another one oz old way she's appears in
the media and like I saw an article
about like the dude she's dating is
older she she just turned 18 or she was
17 he's I don't know how like 22 or
something 23 right so there was like
controversy about them you know whatever
and I was like well why I looked I was
like she's 17 that's not even uncommon
either this show many underage pop stars
that are dating guys that are like 21
two or three and you're like there's no
way they're not [ __ ] and it's illegal
if anyone else did that yeah
but they're famous so [ __ ] it but when
they're famous certain laws don't apply
yeah asus I Cosby you can date underage
people you can rape people you can kill
people kill people deal uh you can just
break laws you can break laws when your
face is like super rich people
shoplifting all the time you like why
did you steal a seventy dollar bracelet
you know what's wrong with you like cuz
they go all I have any dollar brain this
is all buy whatever I want yeah yeah I
don't I of course I can afford it but I
don't have to I'm famous if I was Bill
Gates I'd steal all the time just
because i kid i would just [ __ ] and i
don't think anyone would even do
anything they'd be like oh we'll just
call and say Bill Gates stole something
and they'll pay it I mean you get to a
point of super wealth where you have to
go like yes okay you should be giving
half of your money away right because
half of your money is t does the Billy I
know yeah I know but I mean it's still
billions however money is billions you
don't even know that it's gone yeah you
know you could have accountant that's
skimming off the top you would never
know they asked some who's doing an
interview and someone like the inner
eggs like how much money ever wallet he
was like I don't have a wallet yeah why
would he have an ID yeah why yes I'm
just foot or a cell phone I've beat it
yeah he's just like how they beat comedy
say teamer feed money yeah like I don't
what you probably doesn't think about
money's like I don't I beat wallet he'd
be wallets yeah yeah no gate wallet
wallet I mean boltzmann i plan on whole
different game yeah you wonder the last
time he thought about what something
costs just not a thing that come there's
no way he even looks at that part of the
menu no you don't even that's someone
else's job yeah you know that story
about a roegan in the mill yeah yeah
that's like but that really does like it
capsized you didn't know what milk costs
and don't know that uh i think it was
alright might even re it was our sorry
sorry's on the road with joe rogan and
they're in an airport and this is like a
while ago this is like fear factor you
have see money but you know he's he's
done quite well even since then
uh and there an airport in a walk in and
our egos damn [ __ ] i forgot toothpaste
and Rogan's like so what do you just buy
toothpaste how much is toothpaste like
10 bucks no concept and ours I kaha
you're rich yeah I think he liked he
goes were you kidding and he goes I
don't know what more or less like I
didn't know blue yeah that was well in
that went you're on the first George
Bush ran for office they busted in like
what milk coffee like I eight dollars
they're like no it's [ __ ] 258 did you
know it also have no clue yeah the news
gets so used to a way of life remember
during a campaign stuff some guy went up
to Mitt Romney goes you're rich guy give
me a dollar but Ronnie's like all right
I'll give you a dollar he opens well and
there was only like there's literally
only hundreds here like two grand in his
wallet and hundreds of just you just
like I got ya he realized that this was
going to look real bad he's like hey can
anyone can you just leaves brand new
hundred while crystal court court McCown
um he's good buddies with the earth days
in the Jimmer say owns the Indianapolis
Korea and they're they're very wealthy I
mean you buy a yeah team like that
that's like you know it's not a 20
million dollar tree at cintas if you own
any sports team you have a lot of guy
whose job is to just kind of like be his
assistant but he just goes everywhere
with him and he has a bag full of money
that he's just the tip or guy yeah Wow
where he's like you know give this
watching a football game at for them and
just just he passes out like five
thousand dollars a day yeah of just
passing out money to people door guys
into everything but I gray today no
crazy to just you're just giving five
thousand dollars away today every day I
mean he always want I once watched a
football game at Steve Tisha's how Steve
Tisch is part of like minority owner of
the Giants uh-huh and like he was kind
of joking but someone was like oh I
gotta leave in a little bit i gotta go
to LAX and tish goes where is LAX he'd
never flown to me like he never not
flown private nisswa but where does he
fly out of private that's not an airport
you don't fly the private jets don't
really normally fly
out of airports because they're not they
fly to burbank the flat la out of
Burbank or van nuys cuz you know and now
I mean I've seen in LAX I never seen one
take off though what like g6 is or
whatever though he seemed like in
certain parts of the airport just kind
of like Oprah has a landing strip in ur
[ __ ] up in Santa Barbara that's pretty
vile and extreme up there yep hey
Travolta has one in Florida yeah yeah
like we can just like land in his own
home and driveway yeah or a plane yeah
at your house yeah yeah they don't worry
about scooting their house [ __ ] ten
yards one way or the other I know they
got all the scoots they need a [ __ ]
there's weird things that happen to a
house from having it on your runway from
having a plane like all the molding came
off because we landed every time we land
the molding shakes loose we get up a
guys like my brashness annual [ __ ]
yet is like Ewing all over yours kind of
black from the jet fuel yes right why
did you roses die just jet fuel jet you
gotta replays like guys it's not the
landing in the plane that cost a lot of
mites replanting all those roses it's
killing me yeah like constantly mad at
your kids you like every time you take
the jet you leave me with no dad dad
crab are the jet tonight but take it as
guerrilla clean the driveway because it
leaves all these damn tire marks they
look like [ __ ] I don't imagine you are
grounded for one way few lets them know
check flying yeah yeah that [ __ ] for
that plane stock with peanuts is keeping
me at house at home right I gotta do
another look who's talking this is
[ __ ] [ __ ] I got look who's
talking look who's talking two electric
boogaloo by the way those looking to
talking movies are pretty good uh it's
been so long since I've goot I think I
saw I'm Selleck first one when I was a
kid pelican in who who's the third
gulberg oh I'm talking about guy that
just fell off oh he was so huge yeah all
the police academy police academy movies
you had a run cacoon cacoon yeah yeah
whatever happened all those police
academy movies I think he was in
sharknado maybe and one of the three
shirt
it all his money and his loaded self yo
are you would hope yeah but yeah he had
a real run like he was in every movie in
the 80s yeah those police academy runs I
think probably paid him a mountain
because he really was the star those
movies were big the third one with the
skateboarders in it blew my mind yep
whole bones brigade was how many of
those were there there was quite a few
there was like 27 or anything they were
like 31 which came out last year they
just still pumping notice like how their
shows on like lifetime that are like in
its ninth season you're like what
original programming on cable network
home alone like every year for no reason
yeah yeah they did every now and then
you see the or they like now the thing
is like shitty movies okay c equals
shitty next sequels so shitty that the
actual original people aren't even in it
right and then TV series about it right
yeah you know like lifetime now is doing
like these unauthorized biographies
about bad teeth they're doing an
unauthorized biography about it's coming
out about full house yeah it's not still
of it today and it's just like people
that vaguely look like Jones Davis Oh
wigs and you're just like this looks
dated will save by the bell one of those
oh really uh-huh so weird working at
lifetime would be weird at least they're
not doing like the same old like
Meredith baxter-birney yeah yeah I
survived stories yeah working there
would be weird but you know the bars set
so low yeah you know it's not like
worker you're working at HBO you're like
trying to win [ __ ] homies and [ __ ]
yeah if your lifetime you like you're
just like let's just get paid this month
let's drink Lana an authorized biography
I can see perfect strangers that would
sound by the way great yeah yeah yeah I
loved perfect strangers yeah balc out
greater sure great character maybe the
theme song was so good uh-huh Larry
applet done we can love that show yeah
yeah there's a lot of greats it comes
back I went on a [ __ ] YouTube like
spiral of like uh TV show theme songs
from like I thought of I was like how
did the perfect strangers one go and
then I listened
that and then I listen to the full house
one uh like sure general a pronoun that
by step well although CGI the family
matters one yeah that one too I'd still
know it but they're like they're really
well-made catchy 22nd or thirty forty
second songs that just described exactly
we're about to watch that with the
leaves a real job I believe Alan Thicke
wrote the growing pains theme I wouldn't
be surprised I wouldn't be surprised to
know you get paid good residuals for
that [ __ ] yeah these guys that come up
with us would you like popular on the
radio like the cheers you would hear the
cheers theme song on the ratios are in
those days yeah because yeah yeah
there's so many good ones out there that
is any band like a cover band somebody's
the Billy Joel song yeah great write a
cover band that just so that's all you
do is dtn already exists I guarantee it
guarantee it does to another too good
not to if you just slipped in the
occasional theme song into a set people
would love your like love that band so
yeah like we do covers your do Nick
normal songs and all of a sudden you
just pee would be like what is it well
these [ __ ] learn the stat you
son you geniuses oh [ __ ] with a little
like the punk rock version of the cheers
theme song friends theme song yeah Fred
oh the friends one is an actual song by
a band if you'd have to change it a
little to make it fun yeah what was it a
song first yeah it's a song by a band
called the Rembrandt's yep and it's a
full-length song were the red light is
the band that did that Breakfast at
Tiffany's song I don't or is that oh
that was a blue something if their name
was like I don't remember blue something
I need you now remember deep blue purple
no they were something as a part i think
they were called deep blue some who's
saying breakfast at tiffany's good move
Moon River Blue River Moon River account
no no that's a way older what the [ __ ]
did sing that song did you skate board
as a young man I mean you know what no
is excess right there in Chicago well
yeah I think that's a
huge a factor of it it's like you know
there's only really like five months for
you actually could skateboard and the
roads are such a disaster yeah from but
I mean there's still you know like a lot
of skaters and all that kind of stuff i
mean the skate parks and [ __ ] like that
you knows but i think that is a huge
factor words i hear people skating year
round yeah i mean i tried i
skateboarding especially when like back
to the future came out and in every kid
all of a sudden had a skateboard yeah at
least you know in the Midwest rather
grown up you know everybody wanted to
[ __ ] Mikey boy Edward barrios had
that same skateboard that the the veldt
that is like a black and purple board
said valterra on it my friend Edward had
that board wow that was like a cheesy
department store board that we had like
a cool one that's all that there was to
be found in the Midwest in the 80s yeah
you know that because that skate culture
hadn't really you know uh cross the
Mississippi yet that is the heart that's
that's where most of my nostalgia lives
right now is it's cuz it's so easy to
buy that stuff again deep on something
yeah I think that's the van it's the van
de do you boost American rock band who
are best known for their 95 hit single
breakfast at Tiffany terrible song it
was a kind of catchy yeah but yeah I got
it was one of those really yeah and then
like seven times later like this
annoying song now yeah you heard areas
like this is ok but these are like cat
white imagine writing this song like who
pitched it to the rest of the band
that's like one of those songs that like
if you work at like a restaurant that uh
you know sometimes there are no you're
the same 12 songs every day every [ __ ]
that's one of the ones it's on like when
people go why do you know all the lyrics
to semi Sonics closing time you're like
oh well I worked at a chain restaurant
for some time and I heard it nine times
a day oh weird second it if you have
friends that work in that restaurant or
bar or whatever the [ __ ] and then you go
see them at work or you're in their work
environment and that song cut any
whatever song it is yeah comes on you
like oh I [ __ ] I love this song that
no you don't you wouldn't you wouldn't
you wouldn't love it out of her 587 9
time I've heard that song yet this shift
this year that [ __ ] office with the
desert island five it's like what are
you gonna [ __ ] not get sick of yet
you'd have to go days without listening
to any year songs to tell ya easily you
have to go even just like I'm gonna
listen to one song every four days every
year yes to like it not get tired of it
right because you have the rest of your
[ __ ] life [ __ ] you kinda hope you die
some reason I mean really is that's
another good question what's the last
song you want to hear before you die
happy birds even harder than the top
five like your latley getting I executed
your death row happy birthday to your
last meal and then your last song [ __ ] i
even have hard time last meal last meal
stuff last meal is todd you
automatically want to go I'd want a lot
of things yes steak with a couple sides
that's what you first would think but
then you're like why not i'll just i'll
kill an extra large pizza yeah that
would be [ __ ] easy or did not put
down there yeah peaches really no hard
to know put on that means it's the the
things that you you gotta think in terms
of the foods you kind of never say no to
when they're on the table like french
fries yeah it's like I'm just want ice
cream but for last meal you would get
like even a giant like you could kill
two birds with one stone with like a
giant breakfast but like steak and egg
so you can work a good steak in there
are pancakes pancakes tatertots like a
legit Grand Slam like yes you don't want
to go to hospital at Grand Slam yeah um
yeah but then for the last meal that you
would get like appetizer main course
dessert like a whole have you ever seen
those things where they're like us human
Facebook and [ __ ] like here's all these
famous executions what their last meals
were no I would like to see those I
gotta look that up look it up this it's
pretty easy to find was just talking to
me but at pictures of all of it a lot of
them are really weird really but a lot
of me like damn you can order all that
like some of them is like one was just
telling me about the
and they said in one of them one of the
guys put at the bottom like you better
get this [ __ ] right I'm getting
electrocuted hahaha wow yeah like yeah I
guess up a lot of weird shits got to
come out of that because you start
thinking deep into your like what did I
like when I was a kid or what's a weird
thing I have been able to afford in a
long time you could kind of go just like
Thanksgiving dinner yeah full on
Thanksgiving there that would be good
yeah that would be good right you're
like I want a full thanksgiving meal and
then put the gut the electrocution
things issues shoot people in the back
of the head but you know you don't
always die if you have someone do a
shotgun your brain stamp your daddy
don't always die some people [ __ ]
weirdly live through that [ __ ] yeah they
wit they wheatley live through the
[ __ ] lethal injection sometimes but
the whole reason lethal injection
started because it was like the most
accurate and less least painful what now
they're realizing it's sort of painful
yeah some people don't die right away
dude it there was a I think there was a
guy who didn't die he was like eight her
he's like my insides are on fire with it
cuz like they put you to sleep first
yeah they like kill your muscles and
then your nervous system or something
like that but some people it doesn't
take so like they seem like they're
unconscious right hard like a rock god I
way too much yeah take they just hurt
him really bad so they to do it like
twice yeah what a nightmare there's a
get electric you were they had to hit
him twice it's like or black he was a
dead even name is like uh it's just
hilarious how to keep trying to find
where you're like the most humane way
would be just be not having the death
penalty or beheading guillotine yeah
they should do something great like that
like crazier she and just never have to
do it because it's such a deterrent if
it was like you're going to get [ __ ]
to death yeah like whatever your biggest
fear is that's how they should xq you
yeah right you know they do they like
well you know like illogical evaluation
to figure out if you're saying this is
the the shrink goes you know what this
dudes are really afraid of spiders yep
and you're like okay cool and throwing
you in like a tub full of spiders yeah
oh my god
be the worst now if he ll be rough that
would be all is it I can't even [ __ ]
when I was a kid that's a society I
would not want to live in spiders know
that did that to people yeah I was like
what's your biggest fear that's how
we're killing you it's like yikes yeah
but she our modern day decided we
started doing that it would take two
years before that was a TV show oh yeah
for sure yeah it does sound like a um uh
Dark Mirror but my hair type of scenario
yeah we would turn that into a TV show
and totally I mean it'd be a big
deterrent if my biggest thing if I'm a
gigantic homophobe and if I find out I'm
gonna get [ __ ] to death if i'm a
racist and a homophobe and then I find
out ok if you commit any crime worthy of
death penalty of football you are going
to get [ __ ] to death by a bunch of
black guys right in your ass and they're
gonna come in your mouth a lot so much
so it kills you right I didn't know I
bet honor CT hydrate to death but the
death penalty doesn't even prevent
people from still doing it cuz when
you're crazy you don't care sure you
either think I'm not going to get caught
I'm choose you don't know how there's
probably been times where people didn't
do something because like man I can get
the death penalty for this it seemed
like that three strikes thing work took
for a minute we're due to like this but
I got two strikes yeah that do you did
hear a lot of that too yeah yeah then it
was like when they did do something in
there like they had it made them more
violent that they would more likely to
try to run and like attack the cops
they're like it's my third strike it was
also too broad were like anything like
that there were things that were counter
strike so that were like what yeah yeah
you know like me to a shooter all aboard
yeah and then you're serving 25 years of
like it forever yeah yeah yeah well the
probably got to I got to I will get back
to you I will I will come up with my 5
i'll take it seriously and those two may
change I don't think they won't ambush
our people with that I mean yeah none of
our friends listen to our podcast no one
will know this happened that's true
that's true ye of the people you can
ambush yeah that's right you I can't
believe you haven't seen animal run no
we also don't even have a lot of guests
on yeah so the ones we doing just like I
think David Taylor would be a good
ambush for this one I did I asked in
that a couple months ago and he was able
to come up with like three or four right
away really but then he after four I
think he had a trouble with the fifth
and then once he started thinking of it
a bunch of different ones for five then
he was like maybe I want to move for and
put that one at four so no matter who
you are you can get you either get one
or three right away and then it just all
falls apart once you start thinking of
all the media because you get so nervous
cuz you're running out you only have two
sounds left out of every song ever made
I know that you've ever liked anywhere
from like a little too a lot total so
it's [ __ ] hard it's hard but yeah we
gotta do our art our I just gotta sit
down and be like I gotta come up with
two more yeah in this book it's a
fictional scenario anyway and it's only
for this specific thing it's not the top
five ever and then just we just go to do
it yeah because I feel like for each
song because there's five they're almost
needs an explanation for each song oh
yeah okay go this on this on this song
yeah we have to give our reasons and
right yeah totally yeah you have to like
here's why I chose you know it sounds
like I wouldn't have picked this song I
know and I'm definitely gonna have at
least one of those were people sauces
but you in a good mood because they
remind you of certain things yeah be on
a desert island [ __ ] you know you're
gonna want to like have these you know
that's why I'm like still considering my
number 5 45 to be like a 90s one-hit
wonder that just like is was always fun
always catchy reminds me of you know
childhood put you in a good mood I'm
like maybe I would want that yeah so
that's still floating around in there
yep I don't know it sucks um alright
we're at like an hour forty i think our
37 oh well thanks for doing this hey
thanks for having me i'll get back to
you i'm on my answers yeah that's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] boy it really is it
really [ __ ] in
there's really no right answer nope all
right we did it Jason Tebow your back
how long you been back now a month a
month never [ __ ] left yeah a little
over a month five weeks isn't it funny
it's like you were never gone yeah I
know and there's not much not a whole
hell of a lot has changed yeah that new
back bar the kind of story was new yeah
that's new but it's like it's [ __ ] no
one even by this is a no and I love they
will use it one person Joe Rogan right
yeah they made it a paid regular lounge
and well sweet and then you every time I
walk in there there's like two or three
people where I'm like you're the reason
we would want to come back here to get
away from you right and then they're
just hanging out in there cuz the
problem is the person charge of policing
that rule is the bartender he's only be
a dick yeah they need to have someone to
be a dick yeah yeah and he's being a
dick it's not gonna be a dick to the
only person buying booze from them as
well right you know I mean that you want
to be in there to get away from the
[ __ ] and like annoying people yeah
and then they're like the ones hanging
down there I don't know all right well
thanks for doing this buddy thanks for
having me guys I love both of you very
much and we love you too yep